[Music]
i recently got a little snacky and so
i baked these cookies
this is not an ad they were corn cookies
from trader joe's now corn today
corn tomorrow
it was a true quarantine special they
were so good and you asked me how i made
them
and i said well it was easy it was just
like you mix the stuff in a bowl with
two sticks of butter and you said
what was the butter part and it didn't
occur to me when i was making them
perhaps in my slightly altered state
that two sticks of butter it's a lot of
butter it's disgusting they were
completely delicious yes it tasted like
you were eating like a hot stick of
butter
with with corn wrapped around it
and it had the consistency of eating
butter just it was like crumbly and uh
trying but i would recommend one that's
what the recipe called for two sticks
yeah it wasn't yeah you didn't take it
upon yourself no recipe it was just you
mix three things together speaking of
very simple but decadent things here's
the show life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i am
your butter loving but not unsalted
butter loving uh host justin long life
[Music]
not unsalted butter loving
that's stupid why
it's a stupid way to introduce myself
well yeah it's too late too late okay
should i try again wait so you're saying
you light you prefer let me get it right
i don't like unsupervised it wasn't
clear melted butter much prefer
huh i don't like you don't unsalted
butter it's like you get the
it just doesn't seem right i have an
aversion to
buying
salted butter
what why think about it think about how
we grew up
do you know this no
mom never bought salted butter because
you always had salt around no because
it's cheaper she has the theory that
salted butter sits on the shelf longer
because it's preserved with salt whereas
unsalted butter there is more turnaround
is that true i doubt it but she believes
it's true
and she operated under um that theory
under the the truth of that theory for
her know that our entire childhood she
never could have sworn we had salted
butter no we didn't no i would have said
for sure if i had to guess gun to the
head that it was just cheaper it'd be
funny it's funny the idea of someone
putting a gun to your head for that okay
you gotta tell me did your mother not
buy salted butter why tell me what
what is that expression that's some i
overuse that
because i'm really into hypotheticals uh
that's a really good example of how to
overuse that gun
gun to the head what do you prefer
salted or unsalted butter sauce is so
dark it's such a gun to the head
god uh so yeah you so you prefer salted
butter i don't mind because then you
have to it's always
you have to measure out salt don't you
then add salt yeah you do huh i tend to
buy unsalted butter than add salt this
is riveting oh yes but those should we
do this again no this is great oh great
so uh those cookies were delicious but i
was like the unsalted butter version of
a podcast that's true i will say though
you get more industrious than an average
person when you're stoned
yeah i do i like doing things
very task-oriented i would say you're
more task-oriented stoned than sober huh
that could be a problem no it just means
you might need to smoke more weed it
just might mean that
like you're a candidate for medical
marijuana
do you hear that in the background is
that your stomach
no they're they're doing stuff outside
their power tools men men are working uh
let's let's roll through it okay
men are men are technically working in
here too justin justin hired men to work
on his house as he does a podcast
hey guys guys can you keep it down a
little bit
uh can you oh my god can you can you
keep it down a little is that i'm
working on leslie jordan it does selling
let's jordan well well she i think
it it provides a nice din to this uh
podcast okay intro it's adding a little
salt to it yeah flavor yeah um
well so why are we talking about oh yeah
and being industrious i also hit a wall
i always hit a uh
to get back to this river what am i like
when i'm stoned i hit a wall at a
certain point i can't do anything but
watch
we've been watching beavis and butt head
which is so cliche it's such a cliche
that's the ultimate wall hitting uh yeah
program to watch
oh is it it's so good it's so great but
it requires
so little brain power to yeah to enjoy
it and at a certain point you start
really identifying with bieber's buddy
you're like uh
that's pretty funny what mr anderson
said
mike judge should be good on the show
yeah oh my god yeah i know uh you know
who else would be good on the show oh i
know the reason we're talking about sh
bing stone she would be yes and she was
chelsea handler why are we talking about
chelsea handler in the context of being
stoned well chelsea if you didn't know
this is uh
how do you say an advocate for marijuana
use to the point where she has her own
marijuana company now that has not been
announced but she's announced that she
has a company you know she's long
advocated for marijuana use before it
was now it's trendy and everywhere all
these states are turning and it's
becoming legal which is great but um she
was on the forefront i would say as a
public person
uh one of the many reasons why i admire
her and was very glad to talk to her
grateful
and you had never met her is that right
i don't think you know i was wondering
if we had because an ex-girlfriend of
mine used to have big parties and i know
that they're friends and
i wondered i i or do i just and
sometimes you know people like that who
are on tv
very of who are like ubiquitous you just
feel
i i never remember if i met them or i
just know it from tv or or if you did
meet her it was very pretty pretty brief
yeah well probably like you didn't have
a whole night with her definitely
monopoly and definitely not bad that i
would remember
uh we've had some of those nights with
with people like that and you remember
those nights sure remember that judy
dench night
oh shut up holy crap i took it for a
second i was like oh boy speaking of
weed i bet her
then i made her switch over to a
different strain uh yeah i don't think
i'd ever met her but i had met um yeah
we just have mutual friends and so
chelsea handler is the former host of
chelsea lately the very popular talk
show on e
sorry e
and now she has you mispronounced it
sorry uh now she has a
best-selling book and other bestselling
but she's had multiple best-selling
books she's always had this yeah she's
constantly having best-selling books out
there it's like her john updike and
chelsea hamlet it is called life will be
the death of me
i like that title yes and she i also
like that she's very into
death and that sounds more not in a
morbid way
in an uplifting kind of uh i would say
inspirational way she's dealt with a lot
of it in her life uh at an early age and
she is also very honest and open about
the benefits of therapy and and being
honest so
well don't give it all sorry uh and i
really enjoy her podcast i've been
listening we talk about that and uh we
talk about other things coming up
my
talk
you're you're
yes
i get to find out what chelsea lately is
doing what she's been lately doing
lately again here it is
coming up
right after this
[Music]
sorry about my wacky coloring i don't
know what's going on oh it's whoa it's
very
psychedelic oh my god it's trippy what's
good it's so scary hi
it
it's really weird so it's it's you see
that your eyes are it's like yeah yeah
looks like i have snake eyes hold up i
look like a um let me uh close my blinds
and see if that helps one sec okay
whoa that's so interesting no it's still
happening so i you know what we shot
something yesterday with the green
screen this is unsettling actually
it what it does it looks like there's
still green screen there chelsea like
the remnants of green
[Laughter]
so we shot this stuff and we had like
five different green screens so there
must be some left over weird that's so
weird but i but obviously you can see
there are no green screens there no i
know now i just have green teeth but
we're gonna have to go with it you guys
we gotta go with it i'll i'll get used
to and this will be the way i'll come to
know you yeah and then then when i see
you in person without the weird alien
eyeballs
i'll it'll be it'll throw me well
hopefully i sometimes look like this
actually in person so oh okay
oh that green screen story was a great
cover
um chelsea where are you now i am in la
i'm with um i'm at my house in los
angeles in bel air and my
sister has invaded my house with her
three children adult children and two
dogs oh
oh wow wait this is the sister okay this
is i really want to talk about this
because you i'm also i'm very close with
my brother and i know um i do the show
with my brother and you had an epiphany
that i would love to talk about because
i'm so fascinated by ayahuasca i just
heard your
episode with dan and jenny mullen oh
right um can you describe not to just
dive right in but
i i've been meaning i've been dying to
ask you this can you describe what that
revelation was like um when you when you
had that epiphany about your sister in
the ayahuasca trip yeah so i'm in peru
like you fly to peru i told netflix that
i wanted to do a special about you know
different drugs that's right you filmed
that's crazy to me so i was like what
drugs can i do and where what countries
are they legal in like you could do
mushrooms in in spain for instance and
portugal is legal but ayahuasca is legal
in peru so you had to go for filming
purposes to where it was legal so we
flew i flew with two of my friends and
our crew down to peru which was really
like you know an adventure
yeah it's not cute you know what i mean
so right it sounded that way you were in
some you said it was it was kind to call
it a hut it was like
uh you're sort of it was sounded dark
there were bugs everywhere just the
descriptions i haven't seen the show
which i now really want to
it wasn't it was scary like you felt
like snakes were close by and possibly
anacondas like it was that vibe and also
with ayahuasca there's an anaconda
correlation like when they talk about
ayahuasca it's a snake ceremony and i'm
really scared of snakes so i'm like well
that i don't want to deal with
any anacondas coming up and like i don't
want to face that fear
did you know that going in did you know
what it entailed no i didn't but i knew
that you know we were staying on a
tributary off of the amazon and that's
where anacondas are and then yeah all of
the kind of you know like those little
dresses everyone wears and there's like
fl you know flags of
snakes and and like the trippy
experience so there's definitely a snake
vibe and i'm like i can't deal with that
like if i'm hallucinating and thinking
there are snakes oh my god you know it's
like that scene out of witches of
eastwick with cher remember that do you
remember that no
no i'm thinking of indiana jones now um
that scene as well does it yeah uh
that's my worst nightmare anyway
so i had
a really good experience the first night
i didn't feel anything because my
friends kind of had a hard time and i
was kind of wanted to take care of them
and the second night that the shaman was
basically like you need to be on your
own no sounds incredible that shaman
sounded amazing yeah he shot his pants
twice during the ceremony and i didn't i
would like to go on the record and say
everyone was scared that i was gonna
my pants and i was like hey guys
i'm an advanced drug user no one's
their pants
can i ask you a really disgusting
follow-up how and it may be an obvious
one how exactly did you know he his
pants like how was it revealed to you oh
it was revealed to me with the footage
because the sound of him his
pants once i watched it back because my
dp was like i cannot believe you were
able to stay in the zone i was like well
i'm very good at taking drugs like i
know to stay in the zone and i don't get
distracted so why so i didn't even know
he was doing that normally i would be
very alerted to something like that yeah
sure i would imagine
wow okay so he shifts his pants twice
and are
i would also imagine the added pressure
and weirdness of having it being filmed
was that how did you contend with that
how were you able to set that aside well
i have to be honest like i have a lot
i'm a lot more comfortable doing things
in front of the camera than i am doing
them off camera
yeah yeah the camera i can pretty much
bang anything out and be like okay let's
because it's experiential and i can
convince myself it's good for other
people and some will respect right no
that's true
and there's a crew there that there
might be some safety in that yeah and if
i were if i like for myself i don't
really need to do ayahuasca it's not one
of my like oh my god i want to do it so
but for the purposes of filming it i was
much more interested in that regard and
i was surprised to get the lesson that i
did because
i wasn't expecting i mean my brother
passed away my mom has passed away i
thought for sure
it was going to be about that
yeah the obvious you know the obvious
like trauma ex you know traumatizing
experiences you've had in your life are
there right
attachment figures that you've lost so
to have it come about to be about my
sister and to turn out to be about her
was very enlightening for me and really
had made a difference and i never ever
went back it was just about it was this
voice saying like be kinder and it was
this montage of she and i running on the
beaches at our summer house and martha's
vineyard and tipping each other over and
kayaks and pinks and laughing so hard we
peed you know like in the water and
little giggly girls
it was really beautiful you conjured
such clear images and um just to
reconnect with how close i guess you
you've always been um it was really
beautiful and profound and i i know your
friends dan and had a similar
revelation about seeing himself as a
child i've heard this from other friends
of mine who have done it and i'm i'm now
so much more curious to try it and you
talk about how those memories um change
over time how the memories of ayahuasca
and the lessons you learned
change over time how long ago did you do
it chelsea um oh god i have no sense of
time especially now it's like i don't
know what year we're in
i did it probably around 2016 yeah
probably four or five years ago
that seemed to be a very important year
in your life i know you talk about it in
your book uh life will be the death of
me
and you too
but there's a line in it that i love
that that i feel like is probably a good
jumping off place for us to talk um you
said i made a career
of over hydrating people
without with my honesty and yet i was
being dishonest with myself which left
me operating in a deficit of truth i i
thought that was so interesting how how
has that evolved from the time you wrote
it uh and what lessons have you learned
you know i really just was like kind of
an arrogant and i didn't realize
you know i was just being me so when
you're so kind of in in
inside your own life and you're doing
well and you have all of this success
you're not
i wasn't taking a real look at myself i
wasn't thinking about like a strategy or
a plan or what i wanted to leave behind
or
making decisions you know i was making
everything was impulsive nothing was
thought through and that's fine for a
while but at a certain point you have to
kind of get real and i think with age
obviously that forces the issue because
you start to question like what am i
doing and am i contributing anything in
a positive way
in a positive light so it definitely
made me reassess and kind of recalibrate
and take a step back and kind of get out
of my own ass you know what i mean
i do i definitely do i related a lot to
that and it was around the time were a
similar age
i was going through i think i had a
similar revelation about you know when
you wake up and you realize that things
that you have been coveting are
pretty meaningless and haven't yielded
anything
truly meaningful um
yeah i definitely know what you mean i
think i really uh i really related to
that
how what steps then did you take um
to change your life i mean i know you
you're a big proponent of therapy um
well i wasn't you know i wasn't a big
proponent of therapy but i was i just
was therapied out by this town you know
being in los angeles it's a lot to hear
yeah about this retreat and this trend
and this kale salad that you can also do
yoga too like i you know there's comes a
point where you're like i don't want to
hear about this anymore
yeah but so i was kind of averse to
therapy for a while and also because i
had so many walls up and i just finally
wanted to get real and i knew by
going the first couple of sessions were
incredibly uncomfortable and i knew then
like okay this is something like you
know i've retreated during that time
when you feel scared and you're like i
don't want to un
you know i don't want to unpeel this or
peel this onion or i don't want to
uncover this because it's not going to
be pretty
yeah
the sooner we rush towards that stuff
the sooner we're out of that dark tunnel
so like i knew enough to know that if
this is scary and this is painful it's
worthwhile
and and you mentioned a lot of trauma
that you had uh had had you confronted
any of that prior to your therapy
experience like you were nine when your
brother died i can't imagine
i can't imagine what that must be like
during such a formative time um
did people when you were that age can
try to encourage you to go to therapy or
or to seek some sort of guidance uh they
did you know my parents were just kind
of like it wasn't the time like we were
in new jersey you know right they
weren't really educated and they were
dealing with their own grief so they
were kind of incapable of like
you know i was the last of everyone's
worries because i was the little the
littlest one and they didn't even think
it would affect me in the way that it
did but of course all of this you know
i'm no more traumatized than anybody
else i mean and there are much worse
things that happen than losing a sibling
and the good thing about writing this
book was finding out how many people i
had that in common with you know
my parents once sent me to therapy
because that i think a regular doctor
was like something's off with her i
think i pretended i had polio one
morning because i didn't want to go in
to take a german test at school my mom's
like uh if you think you have polio we
need to go first of all polio was like
out of style when i was yeah i was going
to say you're not around and like i
would say
for sure
i you should have you said like you had
the bubonic plague or something yeah
it's like chlamydia
so
leprosy he took me to the er and at the
er the guys like spent 40 minutes going
up and down my leg with a little pin
print and i just had to sit there and
pretend i couldn't feel a thing
oh that's how it manifests yeah yeah
apparently and then at the end of it
he goes
uh
he shut the curtain door and he said to
my mom she needs to see a psychiatrist
oh that must be a polio symptom exactly
yeah yeah that's fine well it's very
creative of you um
in a way it's kind of like weirdly
impressive uh
melody to come up with were you uh
and you talk about this too in terms of
the differences uh the revelation you
had about your sister that you're just
wired very differently um and you say
that you are somebody who sought
attention whereas she is totally content
having a family is this the one that's
at your house by the way i know this is
another sister see i have a big family
and i've realized being single that
they're invading me you know what i mean
like i always thought being single was
the strength like remaining childless
and with your options open at all times
and that's another reason i relate to
you yes and now it's like my whole
family is descending upon my house it's
like they won't leave me alone i have
nieces and nephews that just come out
you know there's like a constant steady
rotation so i did not get away wow
well which is nice i mean i love i would
talk about on the show i love having
doses of the nephews i love because i
love kids um but i also love what you
said about
there was a moment where you where you
were just like kicking back you were
stoned listening to neil young and
watching the
watching the lanterns in your yard kind
of sway back and forth it was so nice
i've had
similar moments where i as as
you know they're moments of loneliness
of course and there are times where i
think got to be nice to have kids but
then
i i i escaped to those moments that you
described so beautifully the new young
moment where it's like it is really nice
to just kind of yeah yeah kick back it's
also really nice to be able to enjoy you
know to be reminded now i'm conscious
enough
that i'm reminded to be grateful and i
like looking around at five o'clock in
the afternoon and i like you know look
at my yard and i look at flowers in a
way that i didn't look at before i went
to therapy i wasn't looking around i was
just like going you know what i mean
well
totally and and you also describe uh
having a life that was set up in such a
way where people were doing all these
things for you it's that you don't
you're not there's nothing tangible
tangible you're not picking up your own
dog you're not um
and i think that
may go a long way when you're actually
during the quarantine i've been doing a
lot of gardening and yard work and
getting into all right calm down calm
down okay
well well it's been it's been nice to
use your hands you know um that's not a
metaphor
i'm literally i'm literally
unfortunately uh
but but i wonder if that was part of it
too you you described this bubble that
bubble within a bubble that you were in
yeah just having hands it was a lot of
noise and a lot of yeah a lot of
i didn't like the way i was behaving i
wasn't like excited anymore i was like
everyone who annoyed me everybody i was
like oh god you know you could do
anything like get away from me
and so clearly when you're in a constant
state of irritation
the common denominator is
is you not everyone
so that was important for me to find out
about um and that was that's
go ahead sorry sorry chelsea was that
was that scary because um
so much of your
comedy is based on
observing other people and commenting on
other things um
was it scary to kind of get in there and
potentially rewire yourself yeah totally
because there's a period it takes a
while you know it doesn't yeah i went to
therapy for a year and then that takes a
year to sink in you know and then
it takes another year and you're
somewhere else because
first you have to identify you become
self-aware like i became self-aware i'm
like oh this is not helpful or kind
behavior like it doesn't i can have my
opinions but they don't have to be
hurtful you know like you can still have
your personality without all of the the
razor edge
and and then i was like well how do i
meld those two things because you want
your original you want the stuff that
makes you you
but you also want to evolve and be
different and better and always be
constantly you know growing
you know to kind of meld those two
things has definitely been a process but
you know i and it was a
a pretty long period of being really
self-conscious which is not a feeling i
was familiar with like because i'm
self-aware so then i was like oh god
what am i doing yeah am i terrible i'm a
terrible person i'm a terrible person
then i was watching everything i said
and i over corrected you know because i
was like scared to hurt anyone
and then yeah you know it takes time to
get used to like how to operate now that
you know better
yeah i bet i i how how long a period was
that that that period of
self-consciousness and and
questioning yourself like a good year
about a year and a half like you know i
think i hadn't you know hadn't not been
on tv on a regular basis for about 10
years and i think that was like
different and all of a sudden i was like
well wait is my value only connected
to my my identity is only connected to
my work and it's like well yeah because
that's what you've been focusing on
i know another thing we have in common
we enjoy uh nice um we enjoy our weed is
this true that you weren't as into weed
prior to this uh experience you haven't
always been a
weed user having no i came on the weed
scene when when they introduced when
they legalized cannabis in the state of
california because
they had all of a sudden introduced this
like educative component that's been
missing our entire lives and i think
women i know from my own experience
you know taking an edible like what it
used to mean and what it means now are
two different things like you're not
taking a cookie from some ski instructor
in whistler canada like right okay i've
been there done that i know you're not
i know there's always there's always
that leap of faith where you're like
well we'll see what happens yeah right
yeah i've been in a lot of sticky
situations because of a cannabis cookie
but i was like oh a stranger gave me a
cookie i better eat it
what could go wrong yeah it's the same
so yeah now i think with california like
i was so excited when you go to like
these you know dispensaries and they're
all everything's labeled and it's
telling you what the ratio from thc to
cbd is so you can pick the kind of buzz
you want and it was just really helping
me take the edge off because i used to
drink a lot and like celebrate that and
then all of a sudden i'm like whoa
you know after the election in 2016 i
was so angry about that results of that
that drinking and anger were not a match
that wasn't good
no idea
and cannabis is a perfect retreat from
me because all of a sudden you know i'm
in my 40s like i don't need to be
drinking like that anymore
and i don't want to be bloated you know
like
i've noticed i know it really affects me
in a way that even in the last like i'm
i'll be 42 in a couple days but in the
last couple of years i've noticed
a a huge difference in terms of how it
affects me and the day after totally
yeah you know you'll hear about this
when you're in your 20s and you're like
those people i'll never be it's
never going to happen and then you're 40
and you're like those people yeah
yeah god damn it i know
yeah so so yeah and it's funny you say
that if anything there's like too much
information now about
weed about you know you go to some of
those stores and they're like weed nerds
who are like well technically the th you
know
uh well there's a lot of bogus like i
don't subscribe to sativa versus indica
like i can have indica during the day
and i don't go to sleep and invite and
conversely i can have sativa at night
and be fine um
so i don't subscribe to all of i just
like when i i know that certain things
will get me in a workout mood and i know
that certain strains will get me to like
be creative you know if i want to go
through my book and punch it up and be
funny then i know and how do you
how do you how do you learn that chelsea
is it as simple as just trial and error
yeah pretty much i mean
i devoted a fair amount of my life to it
the last couple years because
it was my medicine and so i researched
the out of every brand that was out
there because i was making a cannabis
deal and i didn't want to just slap my
name on something like i want to own
something if i'm going to do this
that's right and you mentioned that that
had stalled in one of the last podcasts
i listened to um because of the vape
situation and you want to ensure that
all the ingredients are yeah yeah so
it's the moving industry right now it's
kind of fluid so we didn't we didn't
launch when we were supposed to launch
and there's been a lot of delays but i
want to get it right i don't want
anything in the marketplace until it is
right because i do feel really
passionately about this and just the way
it's helped me you know it's helped my
sister my friends my family just like
handing out these little
i want women to be emboldened and
empowered the way that men are with the
use of cannabis to me that's important
that women take a little bit more
ownership and are like using it as
freely as men are because
we why do you you know why do you guys
get everything we we need it yeah yeah i
know we get we it's true not a good time
to be a white guy no no anyway that's
our show
um
yeah nice uh we should change the title
uh
not a good time to be a white guy yeah
no but we had a we had a good run
life could be a dream
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
i would love to get you on the phone
with my mother uh just to encourage her
to i'm she is such a great candidate for
weed i think it could help her so much
um does she love well she won't take it
she won't she's afraid even this cbd
i've given her um and you know now they
have as you know
yeah 2.5 milligrams uh
less there's one that's like one point
like a strip um and i know that you you
got brandon into it yeah brandon my
assistant was never he never used
cannabis or drank before he met me and i
was like you need to listen up like
listen you get one life you better have
a good time he's like until i met you i
didn't know you could use cannabis like
that and still be productive
no so that was a good thing for him to
learn and i when he said that i was like
oh yeah i mean i you know i it doesn't
make you less productive that's another
stereotype that's like antiquated that's
right now how do you
but you have to measure it properly
right i mean like i i look if i take
seven eight if i take 10 milligrams i
i'm not the most productive human being
uh right
yeah uh so what would you recommend like
if i wanted to take it during the day
and write uh be creative you mentioned
there's one that you take to be creative
i would take a petrament that's two and
a half milligrams like for that you know
like when i ski i take a petra mint
because it's just a little kick up and
it's like a little uptick
or like those blueberries by uh
milligrams do you know the blueberries
the tetra
tetra yeah sometimes whatever yeah yeah
i like those
those are always fun people love those
yeah i like the uh one of the other ones
um and what is the name of your company
chelsea and when was that we haven't
announced it yet oh okay okay um
yeah i'm probably gonna be called justin
long oh weird huh i mean i'm just
looking up at things on the screen and
like yeah that's what i picked so oh
that well people are people might be a
little confused by but i like it i don't
think i think it's a great name
um what so
i know this is a very generic question
but uh what's the thing that you are now
still
if there is one thing uh that comes to
mind that you're still struggling with
you you seem to me to be so centered and
such a source of sage wisdom on your
show
but what are the things that you still
are contending with
um
well
what am i contending with i think or i
mean you know just
i think probably to be really
comfortable in my own skin you know i
mean i've always
you know i feel like when i turned 40 i
had like a shake up you know what i mean
and i think they call it a midlife
crisis like it's a cliche because it's
true yeah all of these things happen to
us at the same like at the same age for
a reason
so was it just an awareness of mortality
it was it as simple as that or was it
just
i think i was disappointed in myself i'm
like yeah you better than this like
you're being a little spoiled like you
can't even i couldn't work the ipad at
my house to even turn the television on
like things were out of control yeah i
mean
like
you described having two assistants you
call one on the phone to get the other
ones yeah you get the one who's
downstairs to come upstairs
uh so what was that kind of situation
but now you know it kind of steered me
back to stand up which is something i
got really burned out doing so i just
signed a deal with hbo max for my next
stand-up special because i took that i
took that book tour on the road and that
kind of it was conversations in
different cities with different
celebrities
and then i after doing that i was like
this is a stand-up show this is my
opportunity to do a stand-up show that
has like that's profound that's not just
joke joke joke
you know
so
it's brought me around like doing the
work on myself has brought me around to
all the things that i used to love to do
that i stopped loving to do oh that's
great you found the joy again yeah so
like it's real i highly recommend like
anything like nobody ever goes to
therapy and is like i'm worse
you know yeah nobody starts meditating
and it's like i've turned into a total
right
that's right
uh you might want to stop meditating so
much right
yeah that's true so uh oh man i uh
obviously it's the that has been put on
hold now i'm sure uh indefinitely do you
have any idea of when that'll pick back
up
i mean i guess nobody does uh to do the
special you mean oh to do stand up to
tour again oh i know they are opening
places actually i think we have a call
on june 1st to talk about because in
certain states they are like minneapolis
uh texas and i guess they'll see you
know in a couple weeks what the numbers
look like
and what they'll keep open and then
based on that information i mean i'll
have to just shoot it in a smaller venue
with you know fewer audience members
yeah i wonder
yeah or coronavirus survivors
right right
you have to test plasma at the door
that'll be fine yeah there'll be put
people in there for that but who knows
um
do you is there ever anything you're so
outspoken especially uh
now i mean we live in a very polarizing
culture obviously uh
did you ever care
you strike me as someone who doesn't but
do you care about potentially pissing
off
pissing people off or is that not
something that you dwell on i mean i
don't care about it enough to care about
it but it does cross my mind you know
what i mean i don't care about it enough
to not act on it i mean if i don't i try
not to be too self-conscious about those
things because i think the more
self-conscious would become the more
lost we become you know like you're not
you you're thinking about what your
what the optics are all the time it's
hard to really be
authentic
you know what i mean
right and you realize what you do is
honest i mean you rely so much on being
honest i imagine that yeah so you kind
of have a responsibility to be honest
with yourself and with everybody else
and yeah i like to be honest but i like
to start with myself from now on like
it's better to
be self-critical than being outwardly
critical unless you know you're a
republican in this administration and
then it's all
all that's wrong all bets are off yeah
well that's the situation yeah well
unfortunately it's not
um
well i it's also like i i think it's
it's harder to take advice i think
people are probably more resistant to
taking advice from somebody who isn't
self-critical you know somebody who is
self-righteous um and operates from a
point of uh you know thinking they're
perfect so i'm sure it makes your
message more effective like it makes you
a more effective deliverer of any
particular message well i would hope so
i mean i feel like if anybody can rely
on me for anything it's to tell them the
truth you know like my therapy
experience i wrote this book because i
thought oh my god if this is what i'm
dealing with and i've got like you know
every i've got the world at my
fingertips so to speak like everyone you
know
how many other people are dealing with
this kind of like unresolved or delayed
grief
and didn't have the right tools or the
right vocabulary so that's why i wrote
it it just was like oh this will be this
will be great and
to to be able to help people in over
share in a nice way instead of right
yeah and you mentioned that you have
been um meeting a lot of these people or
at least hearing their stories you've
also mentioned the podcast a um a group
the orange group it's like the orange oh
yeah it's called the orange room
it's a facebook private group that is
led by me
for people who want to share like what
they're going through grief trauma
whatever it's really supportive there's
we don't have on there so it's
really nice to have there's like you
know we keep it small it's like 10 000
people
um but it's a really supportive space
and you know it was a good conversation
to open up for a lot of people who
probably have acted
like me for a long time really defensive
really strong-willed like i don't need
anybody you know it was i think a lot of
women can relate to that because you
want to self-preserve and protect and be
strong
are white men allowed
in there
one at a time okay
okay you did say no so now i'm
wondering um uh you had another great
podcast episode with a woman who was um
uh you know sometimes what i call
mediums the wrong name psychic media
right she's a
media
she's a medium and she because i'm also
i'm fascinated and terrified of death
and i've struggled with it for a long
time uh and i know that's something
you've dealt very personally with uh
how did you come how did you meet this
woman and
what is your relationship like with
the afterlife with the idea of there
being something else you seem very open
to it yeah i like to be open-minded
rather than closed-minded you know like
i like to pretend anything is possible i
mean
so laurelyn jackson is this woman that
you know a bunch of my friends in
hollywood were like oh my god she's the
best psychic medium i read a couple of
her books like signs from the other
sentences yes
yes
anyway people love her and people love
to talk about dead people
um and so she
uh
i had her on and she was talking about
communicating like with people that have
crossed over and at that time my my
cousin had just passed away and
they had had a birthday party and she
was talking about unicorns have people
come through with unicorns with orange
with citrus like if you have to ask for
a sign you really have to like get down
on your knees and say hey mom
i need you to tell me that you're here
like show me an orange or whatever your
sign for your mother is you know yeah
and you have to mean it and believe it
because if you don't believe it it's not
going to happen you know
and i have found oranges in the
strangest places and really slope under
a chair lift there was an orange by
itself which had obviously fallen out of
somebody else's but was there for my
eyes to see and it's such a great
comfort it's like why wouldn't you
believe in that stuff so she's kind of
like a conduit for that kind of
conversation to tell you okay your
mother's here your father's whatever
um so but i i also take all that stuff
with a grain of salt too you know what i
mean
right you're not yeah so
i'm not on the phone with psychics like
okay
on the regular like i there was a time
in my life where i talked to psychics a
lot and this oh really oh okay
when you were a kid did you have an idea
of did you were you raised with your
were you raised with judaism as your
relationship yeah well it was mormonism
or judaism so i tried mormonism well
yeah so i took that dreidel and i ran
like
that's funny well because your mom i
didn't know that there were german
mormons
me neither actually
i didn't know there was my mother was
mormon until my brother died and then
the cat came out of the bag because you
know in
judaism you can't you have to be jewish
to be buried in the same funeral and the
same cemetery
right so
when my brother passed away unexpectedly
they had to buy a plot and my dad
brought bought three graves for my mom
my dad and him and then i remember our
rabbi going but rita would have to
convert she can't be buried in a jewish
cemetery so by the time my mom did pass
away and die like 20 years later after
my brother died
she had a jewish she's a full-blown
mormon and we had a full-blown jewish
funeral for her and when all of her
church friends came my dad just said
don't make eye contact with any of them
[Laughter]
only at a funeral could you get away
with that i'm like even my family can't
get a funeral right like you
guys
oh my god
had you met her mormon relatives the
german mormons um yeah well my mom my
mom's parents were mormon and there's
this contingency of german mormons so
yeah we grew up with it and then my
sister converted to mormonism the one i
had the ayahuasca awakening with i don't
know no kidding so she could and then i
you know that was hard for me to respect
at a young age because the book of
mormon i read and was like okay what
else do you got because this is silly
this is not right
i try not to be judgmental but this is
nuts yeah yeah and then when i was a
little girl i was judgmental so
that's a hard habit
right
right a couple ayahuasca trips not going
to solve that
um
uh wow wow you so this is the sister you
had the epiphany about that makes more
sense now that um it's just one thing to
be born into
a belief system like that uh i have
friends who
that is true of but it's another once
your mind is formed and you understand
things about the world to then
embrace that as an adult that's intense
i know it is intense but i also think
you know that's it was a bonding thing
probably between my mom and my sister
like it brought them together and my mom
got really religious after my brother
died because she was so grief-stricken
so it kind of makes sense and comforting
blame somebody for it's just you know
mormonism says like you know if it's
more discriminatory than uh then i would
like
anything to that i would like to
participate in you know yes at least
judaism is tolerant
of of other people of gay people of
people like
and people who are different religions
they don't think they're all going to go
to hell so that's a nice
it's nice no comfort i find but i find
religion all together to be
kind of irrelevant at this point
yeah um and so when your sister stays
with you when that sister stays with you
does it you just avoid the issue
altogether we just pray okay oh you lean
into it no she's a recovering mormon
she's slowly snapped out of it oh okay
okay
who so who's there now they have how
many kids are with you now my sister
here now is she's jewish she was never
mormon her name is simone and she has
three adult children one's 24 one just
turned 21 and the other one just turned
18. so we still oh my god two birthdays
and she brought two extra dogs who are
super annoying oh my god oh that but the
kids must love you i bet you're really
good with kids i mean yeah they love me
but we've been together now for two
months so the sheen has definitely worn
off
the first week i was like come into my
closet try my clothes you could take
this you can by week two i'm like all
right i'm out of tricks yeah we need to
set some boundaries yeah go in the pool
[Laughter]
they've seen the man behind the curtain
yeah
did you ever consider having kids
chelsea was that ever something
not seriously you know i just don't
think that was a good use of my time i'm
pretty really like i mean until this
happened you know i wasn't home for more
than two or three weeks i love to travel
and i do
like i will go somewhere by myself you
know
and i'll but so i i just didn't like to
be i don't
yeah
not my nature but i guess it will have
to be for the near
yeah
[Music]
no yeah uh just
how your d how you're dealing with
quarantine um do you miss doing chelsea
lately you mentioned that and it was a
show that i i really enjoyed uh you know
a lot of people did do you miss that do
you miss or was it just like you got
burned out on it no i loved it i mean it
was fun but i don't i don't typically
miss things you know everything kind of
runs its course but that was a great
time in my life i mean we had that was
like living in a fraternity house and i
was the president of the fraternity oh
man yeah yeah we just did whatever we
wanted however we wanted and if the
network said no i would just go call
them up and be like yes
wow and then you know i mean for a while
was great because the president of the
network was my boyfriend but then he
left and then i had a
real president and i but we just did you
know we were just it was so much fun it
was very juvenile but it was i liked
that about it yeah yeah and you know
it's funny i i remember it's not funny
but um i you feel like you felt like you
got to know them so well the characters
on that show that i when chewie passed
away i felt
like somebody i knew
was gone
i felt like i really got to know him it
was very uh yeah chewie was the sweetest
i mean how could you look at that body
and not smile you know what i mean yeah
yeah um just pure joy um
and and
you've written all these books the one
we're talking about now is life will be
the death of me and you too do your
plans to write another one are you doing
anything like that in quarantine when
the kids aren't bothering you no you
know no i don't uh i like when
everyone's in the same place i get a
little restless you know it's like on
christmas you know everybody's up it's
like i don't like organizing i don't
like when everyone's doing the same
thing so totally i haven't been so
inspired i mean i've actually we've been
i have a production company so we've
been working on that and a lot
you know working on putting writers
together on projects and stuff but as
far as writing material i'm gonna get
there i think in a week or two i'm going
to start because
i'm going to want to film my stand-up
special so that's the first writing i'll
do
uh because i have a big bit in my
stand-up about bob mueller that i think
needs to be updated to andrew cuomo
i know what you're talking about yeah
you talk about having a real crush on
him about on mueller and it's so
compelling that i started to consider
him uh like more of a sexual being than
i had that i had yeah
also for men to start getting used to
being sexual objects because after what
we found out about guys this year it's
like basically it's our turn
yeah it's time time's up for men to not
be objectified um
yeah you do a hell of a number on
mueller uh so now andrew cuomo's the new
your new he's my new crush he's my
latest crush yeah
andrew not chris
no chris is married andrew's on the
market oh oh okay wait he's pretty he's
62. so yeah it's kind of tricky you know
what i mean
right no he's uh he's very impressive
person what about you
single-handedly my advisor during this
time i mean all of our advisors you know
he's the young one in the building so i
start my morning with him every morning
and i turn it off and that's my news for
the day and you know what i feel sane
because of him so like i'm definitely
attracted to that
yeah i've and i wish my parents all they
do they watch msnbc all day and so
they're they're inundated with um
with trump and
uh the circus and
i just wish they would turn it off i
wish they would tune it out somehow
because i i don't think it's helping
their
psychological it's not your blood the
minute you turn the news on and also
it's just like the news is all
speculation and you know right
about right what he meant when he said
it's like who cares what he wants and
who cares what he said
i know i know i know it's trying to make
sense of this of this nonsensical
yeah narcissism is your quality going
you know it's so i hate saying this
because i and i feel like i have to
preface it by saying
of course i know so many people are
suffering now
but so this sounds really douchy and
privileged but
it's been kind of nice like i'm
getting a lot of work done it's been
creative uh
been doing yoga every day um
it's nice for people like it's nice for
the people who can afford to afford it
sit down and think and reflect and take
a break and like stop
i think it's been good for everybody
obviously it's horrifying that people
are suffering in the way that they are
and people are losing loved ones
um but if you can get something good out
of this time obviously that's going to
be a better contribution when it's all
over you know if you can yeah i think
it's helpful and also for the privilege
to be able to stay home longer like we
can't afford to stay home we don't have
to go back to work so like let the
people that really need to go back to
work go back safely while we take a
little bit longer to stay stay at home
totally and having maybe moments
epiphanies revelations like the one you
had in 2016 where you
indulged maybe in those moments of
listening to neil young and
watching i've been watching birds and
literally smelling flowers and you know
just taking um appreciating the moment
definitely did you watch the michael
jordan documentary oh
god i i'm gonna watch it again
me too me too it is so
uh in fact i'm saving the last episode
because i i know i'll be so depressed
when it's over
it's so you know what's so great about
it because it's not even that great of a
documentary it's just michael jordan is
so great that you could watch him do
anything you could watch him tie his
shoes and that's all you need to see he
is so impressive on every level and i of
course i always knew he was physically
impressive i i
loved just seeing that footage but
what uh
his mindset and the way he his
vulnerability and the his openness to
talking about the past and his i
am so impressed by him
i was so great i'm not a basketball fan
or a sports oh really i don't know
anything about any but i i love those
like 30 for 30s and these stories
i mean watching him his evolution from
when he was 21 being dr you know i mean
to
to being this age and he's like bloated
drinking his whiskey like
kind you know kind of still pissed it's
like yeah yes i know the with
isaiah thomas it's like and i say thomas
isn't letting it go and i love that
there's they still have yeah there's
something really interesting about
jordan where he's like he's holding on
to these things that i would think we're
petty we're like beneath him you know
yeah right
right
and yet there's also something charming
about
his like competitive spirit is still
alive because he's a winner so it's like
yeah well obviously that's the way in
order to be that kind of winner you have
to right lose everything else right i
love when he said that i love when he
said you know all the people he had that
moment where he got emotional he's like
you know the people that judge me for
this i think those are the same people
or call me
mean spirited or whatever it is those
are the same people who never won
who just don't win it's like
oh it's and the stuff with steve kerr i
i had no idea about his dad and it's so
yeah moving it's really
beautiful uh
you got to see the third the dennis
rodman 30 for 30. is that look is that
new
no i think it's a couple years ago um
it's just great and there's one about
christian laitner who was a duke played
on duke um and he was like a real
they talk about the pistons from
it just gets in a little deeper if if
you liked any of that detroit piston
stuff yeah i like that yeah
drama for sure oh man the they used
to do and how physical the game was and
how much the game has changed you know
now it's all like but like how about
michael jordan showing up at at dennis
rodman's hotel room with clock carmen
electric because he's in vegas and he's
like get up we got to go to practice and
get drags
like that is the stuff that you make up
yeah and she ran away she's like oh i
didn't want to i didn't want to
embarrass myself in front of him it's
like well
what what do you think he thought of you
you know
uh
yeah yeah it's so good i had heard the
hype around that that documentary was
that everyone was going to see jordan in
a different light he was going to seem
abusive and um like he was abusive to
his teammates and like he was a real
but i i don't know i just i'm so
much more impressed yeah i'm curious to
see what kind of father he must be like
i want to know about that
oh i went down a deep hole of course i
went on the internet i was like who's
the wife and who's the new wife
i got uh yeah i uh i went deep um and so
what's the story how many kids does he
have he's got three and now oh there's
new ones he has three from the
well let me tell you
he has
yes
he has three from the previous one and i
think two of them work for his company
but but but they're noticeably absent
from the documentary yeah they only were
in like two scenes and one seemed yeah i
i noticed that so that seemed like that
was weird but whatever tell me what i
can get oh yeah yeah i love all that
lore though there's one there's a story
that i don't think they talk about in
the documentary about because i used to
love mugsy because i was really short
growing up i was really short and uh
shorter than chewie
uh probably about chewie's height going
into high school i was four foot nine
going into high school
how tall are you
five ten now okay so i i had a growth
spurt like i went through puberty like
the last year of high school um
[Music]
or last year
or last year yeah very yeah
i began puberty that i'm still in the
midst of um
but i uh i was very little so i looked
up to this guy no pun intended uh mugsy
bogues who was
5'3 he was in the
nba and um
apparently the there's this the legend
is that jordan is the one that made him
quit basketball uh because he said
something to him
something to the effect of uh he called
him like a he was like shoot the
ball he put him down yeah
and mugsy was like couldn't
deal well by the way what was he
planning on doing at the 5-3 guy anyway
like how is he going what kind of
basketball was he going
oh he was good he was in the nba chelsea
did he have rollerblades
no he was he would go underneath guys it
was really fun
i'd like to see a 30 30 on him then oh
check out some footage go on youtube uh
yeah i think at one point he was on the
same team as minute bowl who was seven
seven
and minute was interesting because he
was discovered i think in the sudan and
and the the scout who discovered him i
think they lied about his age so they
think he may have been playing
basketball professionally
up until he was like 50 or something
that's also a really cool uh anyway wow
these are such good little nuggets
little nuggets
[Music]
lightning round i'm sorry chelsea i know
you got to go in four minutes i'm
good i'm good
just do what you need to do okay thanks
thanks bro okay uh
well then i'll go really slow
and
i said i'll really drag it out um
if you can continue to look at me in
this condition then just take your time
i've weirdly gotten used to it the only
thing
yeah
even though it looks like i've got a
serious situation on your left side do
you do you have any green on the left
side of your on your shoulder
it must be
no i don't know the chair that's weird
there's no pain in here so like where is
that coming from oh chelsea's probably
on the on the camera itself maybe
oh weird whoa yeah
well it's cool i'm not gonna touch
anything i'm gonna let someone else oh i
think i see your pool um
oh yeah there you go there's like an
image left over yeah that's cool oh
that's beautiful so that's in bel air
you lived in bel air when you first went
to la right you lived with your aunt i
lived in yeah i did i lived it was a
different part of bel air but yes i
definitely lived there and i remember
being like this is where i'm gonna live
whenever i can like as soon as i can
i'm gonna drive through these gates
because i was very materialistic i mean
i'm still materialistic i like nice
things but
you know i came from new jersey and my
parents didn't have a ton of money i
mean we were fine but we didn't have
like what my neighbors had and so i grew
up wanting that and i wanted that badly
i wanted my house to be cleaned every
day
i wanted a pool like i wanted this la
lifestyle so it was
it was materialistic but it was really
important for my for my for me i think
yeah do your sisters t you are your
sisters similar to that or do they tease
you about that
no they're not like me i mean they don't
tease me because no i mean but they they
know that yeah that i'm a little
ridiculous
but i also share that wealth so you know
i don't just take it for myself no you i
know
no i know you're very generous and you
mentioned in the book and you also
recognize the the emptiness in a lot of
it you talk about it in the book so um i
think it's led you to a
really good place probably um
yeah it's really admirable um
okay this is gonna be uh a pivot
something really superficial what is
your most commonly used emoji would you
say
probably the eggplant
i mean it's old school but it's
effective yeah oh it's great yeah
yeah sure especially when it's
inappropriate like when it's to an
executive because you know they can't
even respond to those types of things
anymore
like if i don't want to hear back from
someone like an agent i always just put
something really bad because then
they're like hands off
oh i can't touch that
uh yeah
you can follow it up with the little
squirting the little water droplets um
just as a
that's my tip um if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you play and why
well now basketball because because i
just watched that documentary so i got
all the moves that i'll ever need yeah
yeah who would you and you're in l.a so
the lakers i guess or the clippers i
probably well no i'd want to be coached
by phil jackson so i have to figure out
what maybe he's ready to coach a women's
team you know he's only 80 or 70
something he's got still some gas in the
tank
yeah he seems like he really loves it i
loved all that footage too
i also had i was crushing on phil
jackson which was unexpected i wasn't
expecting that yeah as a player too he
was like um
i didn't know he was such a scrappy like
he was one of those guys like they in
hockey they come you know they're like
enforcers uh but i guess they had it
they used to have them in basketball too
who would just
yeah they would like take people down
they would tackle people um
i loved that footage uh if you could
have one snack food for the rest of your
life what would it be
um
like chocolate twix twix is my favorite
food do you get snacky when you're
stoned
yeah sometimes but there's there's these
hcv
hcv thcv
that is kind of like an appetite
suppressant it's a strain of marijuana
so i'm trying to put that in my products
amazing and that helps with my appetite
but yeah i try i have to say to myself
when i get stoned like
go eat now you're gonna have a real
normal meal and then don't get big okay
how do you do that
god chelsea i need all these tips i need
your weed tips because um
i they're i just can't control myself no
i understand that feeling too i've been
there believe me but and i sometimes you
know do do that i mean often but i for
the most part i'm able to keep my act
together i know to go to my room
i lock myself away especially during
quarantine like the first oh yeah it was
like every hour i'm like i better go eat
something
yeah no i do it now when i'm at the
grocery store i have to think ahead
i have to think with a sober mind about
you know knowing how i'll be later on
potentially i just don't buy the stuff
that i know i want and then of course
cut two hours later i'm stoned and i'm
like and i'm cursing my former self you
know for not buying the doritos or
whatever
um what's your what's your favorite
movie of all time
um i love jaws oh yeah that's a classic
yeah and that's was report that was
filmed in front of our house and
martha's vineyard so i have a
special relationship with the film both
the first two jaws were filmed well most
of it was filmed in martha's vineyard
literally in front of your house then
yeah my brothers and sisters didn't go
in the water for a long time because
bruce the shark was like that mechanical
shark went back and forth
so yeah it was it was yeah i love i love
jaws it just reminds me of the vineyard
it's the happiest place in my life yeah
and and you still have a place there
right i don't i don't have a place there
we sold my dad's place oh oh oh oh uh
have you ever thought about do do you
ever spend time there
we do i'm supposed to go there actually
at the end of this month for two weeks i
got a house for my family to rent um and
i don't i i think we're gonna go but i i
mean i don't know you know we might not
go we'll see what happens oh god i don't
really feel like getting on a commercial
plane so i know i know a friend of mine
traveled recently flew to nashville and
i just assumed it was it would be empty
the plane and they said no no there are
a lot of people there a lot of people
not even wearing masks scary
yeah so sorry to
that puts a damn friend on your plans uh
if you have to live somewhere else where
would it be spain
oh yeah you have a don't you have a
place there yeah i do i love you i love
it there everyone in spain is just so
relaxed
and chilled and even like the nicest
restaurants like it's not a thing to get
in or nobody has to get dressed up it's
just like
it's just the best it's so majestic like
the mountainous i live in my orca i have
a house in my orca and just
one of those places that kind of you
don't really have words for you just sit
there and enjoy the view right
yeah how do people treat you there
chelsea i mean do they recognize you
from
the show do they um
no no it's not too bad i mean once in a
while i mean english-speaking people
more often but i'm not one of those like
global people that i'm like no they
don't half the people don't know they
just think i'm an american celebrity
like that living here you know
a friend friends of mine live there and
they say the wildlife is incredible um
the hawks and the birds that you see are
just yeah and then it's just like really
dramatic cliffs everywhere encompassing
the island so like it's just really um
beautiful
and they and they train for the tour de
france there because it's so mountainous
and so you can take these bike rides
that are grueling
but beautiful too so yeah
one day i'd love to go there um if you
could have dinner with three people dead
or alive whom you've never met
who would they be okay i guess right now
andrew cuomo
of course bob mueller
and why not
and why not throw in chris cuomo for a
perfect little try wow yeah let them all
compete for your affection exactly yeah
um who who's your favorite muppet
of the muppets is there one that you
identify with
oh yeah of course
i'm sorry i asked yeah i mean that's me
that's i feel like that's part of me
miss p yeah yeah uh if you could have
one super power what would it be
to fly if sure other be great yeah um
uh it's funny pigs flying if if you had
to be uh one age for the rest of your
life physically is there an age that you
think ah if there's an afterlife and you
get to just be that age
okay wait you were cutting out a little
say it again
is there an age chelsea a physical age
that you would like to be forever
40 is good
i'd be 40. yeah
okay
um did you have a big party when you
turned 40. i did and when i had the big
party which was at this house i was like
i was like this is it this is my apex
oh yeah
it's not going to get any better than
this they made me this beautiful video
with everybody making you know they had
like private messages for me so it was
one of those things that i watched like
15 times and haven't seen in five years
but it was one of those nights where i
just had it was great i think i have
friends
i think i have friends who are there i i
have we have
the friends that i know that we have in
common just all
really adore you
well i think drew aren't you friends oh
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah um
uh okay if you could be reincarnated as
a non-human animal uh what would you
pick
reincarnate carnated as a non-human
animal
i guess i'd probably be a bear or a fish
bear a bear
oh i just saw the best bear video on amy
sedaris's instagram if you follow amy oh
it's great there's a i think
there's a bear just lumbering along and
there's a
safety comb that's flipped on its side
and this bear just like paused the cone
and it and writes it it's the funniest
thing and then it just keeps walking
around along it's like this anal
retentive
bear it's really funny um
uh would you would you rather be called
unattractive or unfunny
um oh
god un
attractive
okay yeah me too
ideally
ideally neither i know yeah well it's
like what do you value um
and you seem to value
humor uh comedy um
which you don't need me to tell you that
which golden girl do you most identify
with dorothy blanche rose or sophia
dorothy dorothy
for anybody's that's true
that's like sure shut up and off
and that's how i feel yes yes
uh that's funny the beatles are the
rolling stones
oh god sorry okay yeah but i like that
you struggled for a second and then
um and uh you had mentioned
you had mentioned signs seeing signs of
your ma the oranges were how you signs
of your mother yeah yeah but do you ever
see
signs from your brother do you ever
did you ever experience any kind of
vision about him well the oranges
represent both of them like i always
like i'll say can you guys show me two
oranges like sometimes i like i was once
in new orleans and i said i really
needed orange
show me one if you're together or show
me two if you're together and show me
one if you're not together meaning my
mom and my brother and i pulled out and
there was this huge oversized like
stuffed balloon orange on top of a car
and i was in the middle of traffic and
it took literally 30 seconds and it was
in that moment that i was like okay i'm
going to start asking for signs more
often wow so the orange is
representative of both my bro my brother
and my mom
yeah oh god chelsea uh that's really
beautiful that's really incredible um do
you does it come in waves did do you do
you have moments where you just out of
like apropos nothing else you just miss
them you just
think i wouldn't call it missing i'm
more in touch with it now like when i
meditate i'm always like okay my brother
and my mother are right next to me like
i have that in my head and i visualize
like you know our place on the vineyard
and being in the water and like you know
happiness but i don't think like i feel
much closer to both of them now that
they're not here than probably i did
when they were around my mom wasn't like
my mom wasn't up for this kind of
lifestyle in my lifestyle because she
couldn't see me perform live it made her
really yeah so
it's almost kind of like spitter sweet
because it feels like she's always with
me now and she doesn't have to be
nervous and participate in that you know
she doesn't have to go to like
all of these events she can just kind of
watch from afar is what i like to think
yeah she can kind of dip in and out and
if there's things she deems
inappropriate he doesn't have to
uh
see it wow um well i i can't thank you
enough i'm such a fan of yours and um
i've so enjoyed the podcast i feel like
you know i'm sure you hear this a lot
from people but because i listen to it
and you're
you're with me when i'm doing these kind
of mundane
household activities uh i feel like i
know you i feel like i hang out with you
regularly so it's nice to actually hang
out with you yeah it was it was really
fun nice to hang out with you too justin
yeah thanks chelsea thanks for taking
the time thanks take care
[Music]
so
that happened
that's my child and is that the right
your face was more chelsea handler than
your voice yeah
yeah she is kind of so that happened
she's very sardonic she's a very
laid-back delivery very sardonic i would
say
she was
you know i i
have never been very clear on what
sardonic means oh i think you know
yeah you know i had to know once because
we did a promo for he's just not that
into you or he ain't feeling you no more
and uh i had to i had to embody
sarcastic
and sassy something like that and then
sardonic so i wish i had seen your
embodiment but you could have seen it
you know who was it was um nathan bush
my former uh uh someone who worked on
edit the hair stylist on that who talked
like this everything was like this that
was sassy to me
can i not do that sure you can it was
very sassy when i think of sassy i think
of nathan uh and sardonic
was kind of like uh you know who it was
it was um kind of like daria i think is
sardonic i i'm ashamed to admit i used
the word stardom in my life and i'm and
i've never been totally clear on what it
means
uh i look it up why don't you look it up
because now i want to know for sure i
think i think
um
i think it's like um
kind of uh
uh
over it over yeah yeah oh really like
and kind of biting kind of biting it it
always seemed like a cousin of sarcasm
yeah yeah like a kind of a slower more
more
like laconic cousin here we go
adjective
grimly mocking or cynical there you go
cynical cynical yeah yes yes where
everything is kind of like hmm
uh you know who's sardonic is uh winona
ryder's character in beetlejuice
uh
oh god i haven't seen people choosing so
long
but i would say she is sardonic
based on this definition she seems quite
cynical and her show
she's cynical but she's also she mocked
people on her show she did for sure i
think she's gone a different way with
her podcast is really not like that at
all she's very
it's a lot more
celebratory and life affirming i would
say
do you listen to a podcast no you don't
no but i read um a bunch of her book we
didn't get it in time to read the whole
thing but i read a lot of it it's really
good yeah it's really interesting uh she
is the most dorothy of any dorothy guest
we've had she's clearly she's very she's
so self-aware enough to know that she's
a dorothy she answered that very quickly
yes i'm a dorothy
yeah i'm a dorothy i don't take any
from anybody uh oh is that what she said
yeah something like that yeah she is a
real dorothy and i've heard that
somebody was just talking about b arthur
she sounds a little bit like a 50s like
um james cagney
oh yeah he has little james cagney vibes
you know i was just talking about james
cagney on another podcast you don't
listen to called doug loves movies and
doug benson said uh
on which i heard a guy named he has a
great voice his great name i can't
believe i'm gonna forget his name it's
such a good name oh diallo his name is
diallo uh he's like ridley or something
yeah it's a really great name anyway
diallo said riddle yeah it's a fun show
it's like a movie trivia show but sorry
sorry but diallo
said that james cagney never said the
line uh you dirty rat oh really yeah
huh isn't it who said it um
boogs
[Music]
lonnie turns bugs bunny oh really
newton's yeah he made i mean he did that
voice that james k i can't do it the
james cagney boys or is that uh peter
james cagney is too leslie jordan that's
that's because i've been trying to do
leslie jordan lately
well she at hunker downers you know
would be a great show leslie jordan
lately oh yes yes where everything would
remind him of something you know in 1984
i was actually in line at a 7-eleven and
who came in but
uh but tom selleck and he didn't have
his mustache so i didn't recognize him i
was with my friend brandon who was
straight boy from tulsa oklahoma
sorry
uh yeah he'd be great that'd be great so
why did chelsea handler stop doing the
show does he she talked about it um i
don't know yeah i thought when you asked
her if she got burned out by it i
i
was very surprised when she didn't say
no yeah i thought because it was a
nightly show
it was on for years
it must have been so taxing to do
something like that every night to think
of material every night uh and but she
didn't seem to be you know another word
for her on that show she was very
ribbled ribbled and we've talked about
this how do you pronounce that ribbled
ribbled r-i-b-a-l-d body and ribbed his
body she's miss piggy too yes yeah she
is a perfect raw spoon miss piggy yeah
miss piggy and dorothy uh-huh she's
strong she's sassy
she's uh very smart were you a little
intimidated by her yes how did could you
tell him yeah a little bit a little bit
not super but i'm also intimidated by
very bright people she's very bright yes
and uh
she is very clear with her
and may i somehow doesn't i just drifted
off may i suggest this that on her show
chelsea laylee she um teased people
teased a lot of people she made fun of a
lot of people so maybe in your
subconscious you're thinking i better
say the right thing now
because she's probably thinking what a
dope yeah
yeah or what a bad interviewer or yeah
you know i met craig kilbourne look at
that haircut or yeah judging me judging
you i met i i think i probably was
a little i'm not i want to put words no
no no i think i think but i imagine i
would have thought that had i talked to
her only because i knew her that persona
of her so well i had seen and i was i'm
looking at her you know so the last time
i i really looked at her and had had
spent significant time looking at her
she was really a show what did she look
like by the way on you kept talking
about like snake
um you know what it was it's a little
bit like uh you know the predator effect
that when when he's looking at things
and it's all done through through
thermal uh yes queen
yes uh it's a little bit like a minor
version of that effect like there was a
little bit of that effect put on the
screen so there's just it was weird like
one part was
like
have you seen somebody on a green screen
with a green shirt on or like any sort
of green clothing it looks weirdly
translucent no that's what it looks like
what i have i can't remember that's what
it looked like it was strange you know
i'm just recalling now i've met other
people in that vein who were hosts or
had
personas that were
kind of
where they mocked and
and uh
were ribbed
and uh like don rick in a different way
don rickles they're like i remember
meeting craig kilbourne and thinking and
being he's like that too yeah a little
on edge around him like always because
you know she has an opinion that's the
thing she's she's smart
and she's funny and she is good at
cutting people down to size
so
even if she's not going to say something
like that about you there's a good
chance she's thinking of what she would
say
if if you know pressed you know it's
funny i was afraid i'd think that when i
met michelle wolf
and i
felt the opposite from her but she has a
more disarming personality i would say
like chelsea handler sounds like
chelsea handler
i thought would sound uh-huh right
whereas michelle wolf i think
uh had this slightly different demeanor
than i expected i was a little
yeah i think i was a little
self-conscious about my appearance too
because i remember
you look great
christian's referring to my overgrown
quarantine luke
and your rainbow shirt yeah i
i um it's not looking are you wearing
that all month for pride month yeah but
maybe i am because i've seen you wear
that a lot so far in june your
girlfriend just got it for me and i
really like it it fits great it's nice
and soft it says parks project and it
supports the national parks support i
should have led with that yeah you guys
talked about ayahuasca have you ever
done ayahuasca you haven't right oh yeah
you wouldn't know that i but i i i use i
talk about you want to do it yes i've
been wanting to do it for years a lot of
friends of mine have done it i have such
a curiosity should we explain what that
is hopefully ayahuasca is uh
i think people know about it people
probably know it's a
how would you if it's a psychotropic
route in that grows in the amazon
and it's administered in a i don't you
chew it it's in a tea i should know that
i thought it was in a tea isn't it it's
like mushrooms i'm sure there are other
ways you can take it i'm sure and but
you have to have a shaman there uh who
kind of walks you through is your guide
is a guide and i know and i heard
chelsea's episode about it about taking
it and i know there's a netflix special
that she did about it you go on this
kind of spiritual journey i've heard and
i've heard versions of it the thing that
scares me that really prevented me from
doing it was that i i've heard versions
that turned bad that turned dark
yeah and stay stay with you for
apparently the experience is supposed to
really last and um not not that you're
you're pie
for that long but
you have memories of it you have very
clear memories and it and it's
transformative um which in in the good
version of that is exciting and and has
a lot of
i think potential but can you imagine um
you know reliving this nightmarish
situation i that to me
i i couldn't get past that there's
something intriguing about it because
apparently it unlocks
things that are deep deep deep inside of
you right that that
probably will never come out exactly
otherwise and it it opens yourself up to
certain things that you're not being
honest with yourself about and yeah
that's how it's been described to me
right but i think the main reason i've
been afraid to take it is because
uh i'm afraid i'm going to learn
something about myself that's so
difficult to deal with like so i don't
know but just some truth that's that
i've buried that i don't that i'm not
comfortable yeah and i wish i was more
courageous in this way but my fear is
that i would be face to face with this
thing
and
up when i came face to face with
it and i wouldn't be able to deal with
it in a rational way you both have to be
afraid of unliking a deeply buried truth
that will be hard to psychologically
manage
also don't you yourself when you
die that's what i thought you were gonna
say as you're well that's another reason
i wouldn't want to secondary much
secondary you don't yourself you i
mean you you have to be near i think
maybe you can or you vomit you vomit
vomit are you and you have to be
near a toilet but it sounds like when
she did it she was in an amazon if she
was in she in the amazon yeah she was in
peru and she was
in a putt i don't know if they had like
their own bathroom that is a concern for
me too i can't i don't want to
i'll talk about it publicly if you're in
this peaceful circle in a podcast of
strangers that haven't that you've never
met oh i i don't think i can you have to
vomit on yourself i wouldn't mind i
what would you rather do i'd much rather
vomit than
in front of people much rather but
i was just talking really yeah because
vomiting is a much worse feeling a
friend of mine had right
yes if you're alone
if you're alone
i guess you would rather i guess i
have more shame about than
vomiting for i was just talking texting
with a friend of mine and she said that
she has a real fear about vomiting so i
was curious about that what that means i
looked it up there's a word for it it's
like
phobia or something and um and it's it's
it's just a loss of control it's
vomiting it's an awful feeling yeah it
is i haven't vomited in like 15 years i
don't really i almost never vomit but
when i do it's
awful like i it's because you feel like
yeah there's nothing you can do to
control yourself
yeah it's difficult so you would never
do ayahuasca i wouldn't say never
but i don't know if i trust a shaman i
know i'd have to vet the shaman first
how do you vet a shaman that's a good
question
um let's read okay later
jennifer b
subject is quarantine
justin and christian greetings from
harvard oh i gotta i get excited not
that i shouldn't be excited it's harvard
illinois
harvard illinois i don't know there's a
harvard illinois um i've been a huge fan
i'll tell you why i got excited i see
there is a on this letter i'm looking at
a picture of uh what i believe to be a
bullfrog
an american bullfrog and you're reading
ahead i'm not i'm looking at a photo
you're looking ahead okay i looked ahead
so i got excited that maybe she was an
expert from hartford okay greetings from
harvard illinois i've been a huge fan
from day one as justin you are one of my
favorite actors ever since i saw you in
jeepers creepers thank you jennifer
uh i didn't read that properly
quarantine here where i live hasn't been
much different from my everyday life as
i'm considered an essential employee
working in the veterinary field as a
tech
the first half of this year had been
very hard on me as i uh man as i lost my
mom to cancer oh god
and
one month later my grandpa i'm
sorry jennifer
i didn't listen to the podcast for a few
months so i had a lot to catch up on
yeah
well it's understandable i found that
the guests i didn't think i would enjoy
as much as i have
as much have been my favorites
thank you i mean that's cool
the weekend before the podcast where
your love of frogs was shared with the
world my boyfriend and i went on a walk
there was one stretch where both sides
of the path had so many in caps frogs
when you would walk near the edge you
could hear tons of frogs i love that i
love that sound
like little creeks
you could hear tons of frogs just
jumping back into the water
you know they have like a little uh
creak not a ribbit like a like a
that's a that's a good impression after
learning of your affection for frogs i
told my boyfriend we had to go back so i
could take pictures
he was like what's this
you have to take pictures wait justin
long likes frogs and now we have to go
five miles back back to take photos of
them
what do i care
and why do you care
uh i'm probably a lot more insecure than
your boyfriend that's what that's what
that just revealed
this time we came from a different
direction and had to bike five miles to
get there oh my god they biked back five
miles
sadly because it has gotten hot the
water had mostly dried up so we only
found one frog i've attached the picture
for you thanks for the laughs jennifer
uh
that's a big one i think
yeah look at that one that's a bullfrog
i believe it's a bullfrog and you'll
know say it again
bullfrog
chelsea has a hard time with that word
bull bull ball
ball wasn't there a show called bowl
uh there's a show called bull
ball with michael weatherly michael
weather are you impressed i know that
impressed is not the right word
um
i'm surprised yeah bullfrog it's the
largest frog in north america
whoa yeah the american and you'll know
this sound if you ever hear this it's
like
oh they call them cow frogs they sound
more like cows oh bull i wonder if
that's where it comes from
okay cool thank you thank you jennifer
jennifer anne thank you to jennifer's
boyfriend for being a good sport yeah
for being uh secure and being uh cool
with going back five miles
take a photo
um thank you thanks i'm so sorry that
you you sounds like you've had a real
rough year but also sounds like you have
a
supportive boyfriend now that it's all
about
a man and a nice new pet
oh yeah
um if you guys want to say she likes
frogs or she just is noticing them now
because of we talk about it and she
notices them yeah
the sound is i think just have the best
sound if you are very unique if you guys
would like to write in you don't like
frogs do you i do like frogs
yeah i mean what do you mean like
like the same way you like do i covet
them
no no
you like hearing them most what do you
like most about them i like seeing them
hop you do sure okay but i wouldn't go
five miles out of my way to look at one
i'll tell you that
you know i don't think i would uh
okay well thank you to jennifer and to
jennifer's uh whole family and if you
guys want to write in our email address
is life is short at wondry.com
and
thank you to chelsea handler yes the uh
intimidating but yes because she's so
the sardonic yes bright
uh chelsea repressive impressive
impressive that she's done so much work
on herself
and that she's so self-aware and um and
she's such a big proponent for weed and
yes and thought she's really i i really
admire thoughtful people who have
um worked on their own lives
i think that's very impressive me too i
i she's somebody i think is yeah she's
very admirable
very inspiring um and so check out her
podcast check out her book which is
called
life will be the death of me
by
chelsea handler
yeah it's great and uh she's fun to
follow on instagram too i um
i've been following her does she follow
you back
i don't know i don't think she does haha
actually i don't know i shouldn't say
that okay um yeah okay uh we'll see
y'all next week
y'all i am country now
what about bob anyway
life could be a dream
[Music]
life is short it's hosted by me justin
long i've done this 67 times it's
produced by christian long was his hands
down his pants on my thigh and by megan
monaco senior producers michelle miesh
lans audio engineer is
sergio surge protector enriquez our
executive producers are marshall louie
and hernan lopez
for a company called wandery wonder how
they got that name
look at this i saved a possum in
their side yard that's my hand oh crow
where are you going i saw this kid me in
our house in theater i saved him and
there were workers in ourselves so cool
he was in the yard late at night and
this is the
i lived across from the whole foods in
miami and the whole the flights
and there were two workers two men
poking it and i go what are you doing
and i
saved him that's cool and i called every
place in town trying to rescue him and
some lady called the possum queen who
became called the possum queen yes i'm
friends with on facebook because she
would rescue them as the only people
and i needed theodore there were that
many pop homeless possums i didn't know
either
she was a lady she was the only person i
could get to sure she didn't like she
was like a possum thief she wasn't like
taking them no
where are they rescued from they're not
like dogs
um she would bring them home but from
where
people like me like search because no
one is
[Music]
you guys
you